Christopher Nolan's epic Batman series
ended on a somewhat confusing notes
Batman was essentially dead Bruce Wayne
were tired in Italy and all the villains
met a slow dramatic end but her P
resolution seemed to bring yet another
cliffhanger so what exactly happens with
the finale of The Dark Knight Rises he
is an explanation of what really went
down in the ending of Nolan's Batman
series and what it meant and still could
mean for the future
blast survivor during the climax of the
movie Batman scoops up the bomb
threatening Gotham with his bat pod and
the shoots off toward the ocean as fast
as he can
where it eventually explodes at a safe
distance from the city that now dead
Batman is finally hailed as the hometown
hero he was all along and Alfred heads
to Florence likely holding on to a
sliver of hope that he'll find Bruce
Wayne living a new life as a quiet
family man just as he described at the
beginning of the film ahead dish
fantastic I would look across the tables
and I'd see you there we don't wife of
course Alfred does spot Bruce lunching
with Selina Kyle in a pitch perfect
resolution that well seems almost too
good to be true
and for many viewers it was some fans
interpreted this as another instance of
Christopher Nolan's spinning top style
trickery they saw the scene of Wayne's
perfect retirement as a part of Alfred's
imagination but Christian Bale says what
we saw was what we got my personal
opinion is no twas not a dream did that
wish for real the fact that Lucius Fox
later discovers that the autopilot
function on the bat had been restored by
Bruce himself certainly lends some
credence to Alfred's vision to the light
Knight Rises if Batman was the Dark
Knight then Officer John Blake as the
franchise as Robin it's certainly a
lighter shade of Justice you see I like
that name Robin
the orphan boy turned on his Scarpa was
a champion of kids in need and helped
reconnect Wayne Enterprises with the
orphanage had grown up in
he's also the perfect person to take
over and become the city's newest masked
hero in Batman stead a future that was
heavily hinted at when he found the
Batcave at the end of the film we don't
get to see what his crime-fighting style
might be like but based on his do-gooder
attitude throughout the collapse of the
city Blake could be an optimistic
successor to Wayne's tenure as Gotham's
resident hero so the movie's closing
moments where Blake gets the key to the
cave asks the obvious question room for
a sequel it's been several years since
the Dark Knight Rises closed out Nolan's
Batman trilogy but the ending to the
film definitely left the door open to
more exploration of his grim vision of
Gotham City with Blake taking over the
Batcave and to plenty of villains from
the comics waiting for their turn on
screen there's a ton of material to make
this film series a quadrilogy or even
larger unfortunately the would-be star
of such a sequel Joseph gordon-levitt
has cast doubt on the idea of Nolan's
series ever getting a fourth installment
he told cinema blend I think no than
very much sort of that movie as a
conclusion and there's a theme that runs
through all three of these movies up
begins in the first movie runs through
the second movie and it concludes in
that moment where he says our Batman is
more than a man
Batman is a symbol and so to have
another man other than Bruce Wayne kind
of becoming Batman at the end of that
trilogy I think that's the perfect
ending to that story but still even if
Nolan and gordon-levitt aren't
interested in returning to the material
another filmmaker could in theory pick
up where Nolan's series left off
somewhere down the line after all Bryan
Singer's Superman Returns or was a
sequel to Superman - 26 years later and
a singer straight-up ignored Superman 3
& 4 so never say never setting a tone
before the dark night the Campina some
1997's Batman and Robin derailed the
Caped Crusader's movie bankability by
freeze
but the end of Nolan's series signified
a major tonal shift giving us a much
more serious and dramatic style than the
previous set of Batman films that knew
more grounded view of DC's comic-book
characters would become something of an
inadvertent standard for the DC Expanded
Universe films to follow just look at
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice is
grim gritty version of Batman the same
dark tone colored the palates of Henry
Cavill Superman and the Justice League
looks like it's heading in the same
direction and that that's not the only
precedent Nolan's film set for the
battle world either the standalone
series everyone knows that shared
comic-book universes are all the rage
right now after all there's a lot of
money to be made by dangling one piece
of the shared universe as a must-see for
the eventual Super Hero smash film
that's coming soon from each studio even
Harry Potter has gotten in on the sequel
prequel spin-off game but the Dark
Knight film proves that an endless
extension of a beloved property isn't
always necessary to rake in the big
bucks and earn respect at the same time
while sequel hopes might always loom
over Nolan's trilogy it currently stands
alone as its own three-part series that
earned a lot of respect from critics and
had audiences forking over their cash at
the same time it's hard to imagine what
might have become of the series if Nolan
had allowed Warner Brothers to spin the
franchise out into a shared universe of
its own
but the fact is that he didn't and his
movie still accomplished everything they
meant to hopefully future filmmakers
will look back at his trilogy and its
standalone ending as the perfect way to
handle high-profile properties for the
next generation thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]